bien sería evoca un país de guerra desde
hace más de 10 años también se ha vuelto
un narcoestado la razón el comercio
lucrativo del captagón esta droga
derivada de un tratamiento que alguna
vez fue legal para el trastorno de
atención se ha convertido en el gran
narcótico del Golfo según el servicio de
seguridad Siria es la Fuente del 80% del
suministro mundial este comercio
representa por lo menos tres veces el
presupuesto nacional es la mayor
exportación de Siria
eclipsando todas sus exportaciones
legales juntas según los datos oficiales
envían en grandes cantidades si en cajas
Por ejemplo si en cajas generan 180
millones de dólares
el valor de cada píldora va desde un
dólar para aquellas que son adulteradas
y de baja calidad hasta los 25 dólares
por las tabletas Premium vendidas en
altas esferas los Testigos e integrantes
del comercio de captagón en Siria
confiaron a afp que el hermano del
presidente
está involucrado en este negocio
abasteciendo algunos laboratorios con la
materia prima del captagón él es también
jefe de la unidad Elite de Siria
esta unidad controla gran parte de la
frontera con Líbano un camino clave para
el comercio de la droga que luego
atraviesa Jordania antes de llegar a su
mercado principal Arabia Saudita el
mercado Saudita es el más fuerte solía
ir de aquí a Dubai o de Siria a Jordania
y Arabia Saudita o de Dubai a Arabia
Saudita de África a Arabia Saudita De
cualquier manera Todo llega a Arabia
Saudita hay una gran demanda allí
en medio oriente se incautaron 400
millones de píldoras tan solo en 2021
una cifra que las autoridades esperan
que se multiplique para este 2022 Pero
según los funcionarios de aduan asiática
narcóticos entrevistados por afp por
cada envío que frustraban otros nueve
llegaban a término